>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Nancy Groce: David
Bromburg, it's always great
to have you back here at
the Library of Congress,
thank you so much for coming.
>> David Bromburg:
Thanks for having me.
>> Nancy Groce: And
you're here to talk
about your American
violin collection.
>> David Bromburg: Yes,
I brought a violin today
that was made in Baltimore.
And I think the idea today is to
contrast the way that fiddlers
and classical violinists
use the instrument.
>> Nancy Groce: Yes,
because people use those
terms interchangeably.
In fact, what was the story
you were telling me before?
>> David Bromburg: Well,
Itzhak Perlman always called
his instrument his fiddle,
and Vassar Clements who was one
of the world's greatest fiddlers
always called his his violin.
>> Nancy Groce: And--
>> David Bromburg: So go figure.
>> Nancy Groce: So is
it the same instrument?
>> David Bromburg: When people
ask me what the difference
between a fiddle and a violin
is I usually say around $10,000.
It is the same instrument.
It's what you can
afford and what you like.
Although, fiddlers and
violinists, fortunately,
like different kinds of sounds.
There's also different sys--
violinists like something
that will cut
through a 40 piece orchestra.
The first overtones you use
when you're playing with a bunch
of other musicians
are the lower ones.
So violinists gravitate
towards things
with a strong upper-sound,
a penetrating trebly--
more penetrating trebly sound.
And the only instruments
that have both
that in a warm quality are
Guarneri Del Gesu violins.
And this is a copy
of a Del Gesu,
that doesn't mean it's going to
have that, but this one does.
>> Nancy Groce: And what do
fiddlers-- what do they like?
>> David Bromburg:
They like a warm sound.
They like a warm sound and
if they want to be louder,
they'll use a microphone.
And also, fiddlers
don't care who made it
or how broken it's been.
If it works for them,
it's enough.
Which seems to me,
pretty sensible.
>> Nancy Groce: Now, you
study to be a violin maker
and you have a very
important violin shop
and you're acquired a
very important collection.
And I know you came by a
while ago with a number
of violins made just in Chicago,
but today you've brought
something closer to Washington,
you have a Baltimore instrument?
>> David Bromburg: Well,
Luther Heiges was born
in York, Pennsylvania and--
>> Nancy Groce: He was a fiddle
maker that made this fiddle?
>> David Bromburg: He was a
good violin maker who made this,
and people-- there's
been a lot of speculation
and incorrect information
about him.
People thought maybe
he was born in Germany
because his name is kind
of German; H-E-I-G-E-S,
and nobody knows how
it's really pronounced,
I just assume it's Heiges.
And his father was a
machinist and he was born--
well, some sources
say he was born
in 1900, he was born in 1867.
And he went to the
Maryland Institute--
I don't think I'll
get the name right,
but it was the famous
Maryland art school.
And he graduated in 1900.
And the--
>> Nancy Groce: And he
graduated as a musician?
>> David Bromburg: No, in I
think as a mechanical designer
as a-- his father
being a machinist,
I think it had to
do with machines.
>> Nancy Groce: Oh, okay.
>> David Bromburg:
He was fascinated
with machines his whole life.
I think along with violins,
like many machinists
and mechanically oriented
people, he was fascinated
in the machinery of a pistol.
And he was a member
of a pistol club
and was actually the
president in 1924 of a club
that graduated an
Olympic medalist.
So he had an interesting life.
1900 was a very significant
year for him,
because he graduated--
no, I was incorrect.
He graduated from
the school in 1893.
>> Nancy Groce: Okay.
And when did he start
making violins?
>> David Bromburg:
He was first working
in different violin shops
in 1900 that we know of.
But also 1900 the census listed
him as a foreman in a foundry.
But evidently, at some point
in 1900 he began working
in different shops.
And I do know through anecdotal
information that he used
to frequent the shop of Alberto
Molier [phonetic] in D.C.
>> Nancy Groce: Oh.
>> David Bromburg: And I
think that he received a lot
of information from Molier.
>> Nancy Groce: And
you know the Library
of Congress had a long
relationship with Molier
with our instrument
collection here also.
>> David Bromburg:
What a brilliant maker.
He was one of America's best.
>> Nancy Groce: And
you've brought one
of the Baltimore maker's.
>> David Bromburg: Yeah.
>> Nancy Groce: Can we
start by just seeing?
Explain to us what
we're looking at here.
>> David Bromburg: Well,
it's built along the pattern
of a Guarneri Del Gesu.
The workmanship was really good.
He was especially good at
inserting the purfling,
which are the-- people don't
know exactly what they are,
I'll tell you, it's
three strips of wood;
a black, a white and a black.
And it's not the easiest thing
to do to put this without lots
of gaps and especially
on the tops.
But he was quite
skilled at that.
And the purpose of this
stuff, for one thing,
violins look really
crazy without them
and there are some without it.
But the other is, if
the wood is broken here,
it'll break at the purfling
and the break won't
go inside any farther.
>> Nancy Groce: So
it's to protect the--
>> David Bromburg: To protect.
The back is strong enough
so you don't really need it,
but it's also purfled.
And on some violins, especially
hedges because he did a lot
of fancy purfling,
you'll find designs.
On this one he was a little more
subtle, he did his last initial
down at the bottom in purfling--
>> Nancy Groce: Aw, yes.
>> David Bromburg:
There's a little H there.
>> Nancy Groce: Oh,
that's beautiful.
And the back is beautiful,
what kind of wood is that?
>> David Bromburg: This is
slab cut maple and I believe it
to be American wood
from the markings.
The other really wonderful
thing about his violins,
I think his varnish
is just beautiful.
You can see there's a
very fine crackle to it,
which usually indicates
the presence of a lot
of oil in the varnish.
And such a good varnish,
this is not something
that he would've gotten
from Molier because although
in the classic period,
Stradivarius
and all his contemporaries
bought their varnish;
they had to.
They were members of the
guild and the first law
of the guild is you have to
patronize the other guilds.
And before this was really
brooded about I figured
that they had to have bought
it because one of the ways
to identify what city a violin
was made in from that period
in Italy was the varnish.
The varnish of all
of the violins has a
certain similarity--
>> Nancy Groce: So there's
been a lot of mysticism
about violins and the--
>> David Bromburg: And varnish,
you know, but the secret
to the old varnish was lost.
Because around the late 19th
century they discovered lacquer
from Japan.
And it was so much
easier to apply,
that everybody started
doing that
and didn't patronize the
apothecaries who used
to make the old varnish, and
so the recipes were lost.
>> Nancy Groce: Now,
tell me more
about violin making
in Baltimore.
Were there a lot
of violin makers?
>> David Bromburg: There were.
However, I have not been able
to identify a school of making.
In other words, I--
In Pittsburgh you had
a guy named Francois,
GM [phonetic] Francois, and
he influenced all the makers
in Pittsburgh, and Chicago
was John Hornsteiner.
But most places there was
not one dominant maker,
there were quite a few very
good ones in Baltimore.
>> Nancy Groce: Do we know how
many violins this maker made?
>> David Bromburg: I
believe, if my memory served,
that he made somewhere
around 130.
>> Nancy Groce: And so
you've seen other ones
or do you have other ones?
>> David Bromburg: Oh yes, I've
seen quite a few other ones,
that's how I know that he
used to do fancy purfling.
And the point I was trying
to make about the varnish,
by the way, is he couldn't
have learned that from Molier
Because in modern times, in the
19th century and 20th century,
anybody with a good varnish
wouldn't tell anybody else how
to make it.
>> Nancy Groce: Oh, so it
went from being a guild secret
to being a personal secret?
>> David Bromburg:
I don't think it was
at all a secret in
the 19th century.
There are letters
from Lupot to one
of his colleagues saying
I ran out of varnish
if you could send me some.
>> Nancy Groce: Really?
>> David Bromburg: Yeah.
Yeah, but it became a
secret after a while.
>> Nancy Groce: Now, what
year was this violin made?
>> David Bromburg: This was made
in 1917, so it's 100 years old.
>> Nancy Groce: And was it in
good shape when you acquired it?
Did it need much work?
>> David Bromburg: No, no,
it was in pretty good shape.
And I used to see quite a
few of them around Baltimore.
Now they are, thankfully,
very much sought after.
>> Nancy Groce: Now, at one time
American violins weren't valued
very highly.
Could you talk a
little bit about that?
>> David Bromburg: Well, I
think it's probably embarrassing
to the violin dealers
of the before the 90's.
>> Nancy Groce: The 1991's?
>> David Bromburg: The 1990's.
Because when I started
collecting American violins I
was told there were
no good ones.
And I can't understand, those
guys had eyes, they could see,
and they should have seen that
these are beautiful things.
And they didn't!
>> Nancy Groce: So you started
to acquire American violins?
>> David Bromburg: Yeah.
I started-- every time-- I
make my living as a musician,
and every town I would visit I
would visit the violin makers
and ask them if they had
any good American violins,
and they'd say something like
oh, no, there aren't any.
Oh, you know, there was a guy
around here, he wasn't too bad,
but I got one in the back, it's
not worth my while to fix it.
And so that's how it started.
And when I started lecturing
some of the American societies
and showing what American
violins looked like,
people who had even had them
in their shops sometimes
never really looked at them,
they just looked at the label,
saw that it was American
and who cares.
And it was interesting to run
into players who would say oh,
my second violin is an
American violin, and you know,
it sounds really good.
Well, Americans are not
genetically inferior
to Europeans.
The usual excuse after
"oh, they're all German"
or they're all something else,
which doesn't fly, was "well,
we don't have the
apprentice system here,
and they have that in Europe."
And well, actually, most
makers did begin to learn
from someone else but
it wasn't official.
But the real kicker is in Europe
there were tens of thousands
of people who were
apprentices and then journeymen
and then had their own shops.
How many of them
were really good?
Tiny percentage.
So that's not what
makes you good.
And it's my theory that what
makes a good violin maker is a
combination of natural talent,
lots of natural talents,
not just skill with your
hands but skill with observing
and figuring our what's good.
But then the other
thing is you have
to have seen iconic instruments.
If you don't ever see
a really good violin,
you'll never be able
to make one.
>> Nancy Groce: Because
it's so much tradition
and copying the excellent
fiddle makers,
violin makers, from before?
>> David Bromburg: Also, there
are mathematical principles.
The makers of the
17th and 8th century
when the world's greatest
violins were made,
were very interested
in mathematics,
the ones who could design
violins, and there were very few
who designed their violins.
Stradivari was one.
They were very interested
in the golden section;
the idea of two-thirds which
is dominant throughout nature.
If you look at a sunflower
or any seeded thing,
you'll find that every circle
of seeds in a sunflower,
the inside one is two
to three on the outside.
>> Nancy Groce: That goes back
to Pythagoras, doesn't it?
>> David Bromburg: Yes.
Yeah, yeah.
And also the scrolls are
based on the Nautilus.
And again, in the
beginning you do see the two
to three relationship but it's
very important of the structure
of the body, and there're
measurements that work better,
you know, they just do.
And if you have never
studied one--
Bob Bine, who unfortunately
we've lost,
was a great violin expert.
And he used to tell
me that when he'd look
at an old Italian violin,
he immediately put it
into one of three categories.
It was either made by one of
the very few violin makers
who could design a violin
from scratch, or it was made
by someone who worked in
their shop and knew how
to use the templates and forms
and tools, or it was made
by somebody who only saw one of
those violins and got some of it
and missed some of it.
So I thought that that
was a very instructive way
to look at violins.
>> Nancy Groce: Now, you have
acquired the largest collection
of American violins
over the years.
>> David Bromburg: I think
there have been larger ones,
but they were not
guided necessarily
by a knowledge of violin-making.
My collection is of
prime examples of some
of the best makers, as
many of the best makers
that I could assemble.
>> Nancy Groce: So you've
curated it very closely
over the years?
>> David Bromburg: Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, you know, I mean, as I
learned more, my taste improved
and the collection would
change in character.
>> Nancy Groce: And how
many violins do you have no
in this collection?
>> David Bromburg:
Right now it's 263.
>> Nancy Groce: That's
very impressive.
Well, what I'd like to do,
I know you've brought two
very talented violinists
with you today, one
that's classically trained
and one traditional player who
plays with you in your band.
>> David Bromburg: Yeah.
>> Nancy Groce: And what I'd
like to do is have them come
and show us what this
particular violin sounds like.
>> David Bromburg: I
think that's a good idea,
I picked this one--
one of the reasons is
because it has those qualities
that both classical
players and fiddlers like.
And that's a rare
violin, usually they're
over to one side or the other.
>> Nancy Groce: So it's like
a continuum and some people--
>> David Bromburg:
Yeah, kind of, yeah.
>> Nancy Groce: But this is
a good all-around instrument?
>> David Bromburg: This is a
fine all-around instrument.
I think they would
both tell you that.
>> Nancy Groce: Well, let's
hear what they have to say.
Thank you so much.
>> David Bromburg: Sure.
>> Nancy Groce: Good morning!
Thank you so much for coming
to the Library of Congress.
I want to welcome Kenneth
Naito and Nate Growler,
both of whom play violin,
different types of violin
and we're going to discuss that.
And we have an example from
the David Bromburg collection
of a Baltimore violin that
both Kenneth and Nate are going
to play on, and we'll just
maybe discuss the difference
between fiddles and violins.
>> Nate Growler: Alright.
>> Nancy Groce: And today we
have a Luther Heiges violin.
Is it important what kind of
instrument that you play on?
>> Nate Growler: Ah, yeah,
it's definitely important.
I mean, as a fiddle player,
I gravitate towards fiddles
that are a little
bit darker sounding.
>> Nancy Groce: Like deeper?
When you say darker
what do you mean?
>> Nate Growler: Darker--
deeper is probably a
good way to put it.
I guess maybe one thing
that I tend to shy away
from is something
that's really bright.
I think maybe classical players
like a little bit
brighter sound, but I--
fiddle players, you know, we
always play in a mic, typically,
so we want something that's
kind of warmer, darker,
and we can just put a mic on
it and we don't really have
to worry about reaching the
back of the room so much.
>> Nancy Groce: Does
that blend better
with the ensembles
you play with?
>> Nate Growler: Yeah, I
definitely think it does,
in bluegrass music with lots
of mid-range kind of things;
guitar and banjo, I
think it kind of fits
into the sound a little better.
>> Nancy Groce: And
Kenneth, what about you?
What's your ideal violins.
>> Kenneth Naito: Well,
as a classical violinist,
when I go search for a violin
I tend to go for a violin that,
for example, on the G
string which is the--
>> Nancy Groce: Which
one's that?
>> Kenneth Naito:
This one right here.
It's the one that has
the lowest pitch, right.
Tends to have a more
deeper, more darker I guess
in a sense sound,
and more brighter
on the high pitched string
known as the E string.
>> Nancy Groce: Which
is the one on this side?
>> Kenneth Naito: This
one on this side, yeah.
And so I like to
also have a violin
that has a very smooth sound
as well, something that--
because when you're on a
stage, the violin needs
to project very well because we
don't use a mic when we play.
I also like to go for a violin
that has a very nice sound
that can project
through in a big hall.
And also has a nice
ringing tone to it as well.
So, yeah.
>> Nancy Groce: So--
>> Nate Growler: I think
this is a great balance
of those two things.
>> Kenneth Naito: Definitely:
>> Nate Growler: It's
got the darker qualities
but it has a really nice
focused kind of punch
to it where it projects.
>> Kenneth Naito: Yeah,
I really want to--
this violin also has a
really nice smoothness to it
that is really hard to find
when looking for a violin.
Like, the tone when you
play, it doesn't break,
it doesn't like jitter, it's
just when you put the bow on,
just very smooth sound, yeah.
>> Nancy Groce: Well, David's
point was that there are a lot
of great violins, fiddles,
whatever you call
them, made in America.
So, maybe if we could hear both
of you play a little bit on it,
people can get an idea of
this particular instrument
and the differences
in your styles.
So who wants to go first?
>> Kenneth Naito: Well, you're
the one holding the violin, so--
>> Nate Growler:
Rock, paper, scissors?
[ Laughter ]
>> Nancy Groce: But you're
the one on the end, actually.
Maybe--
>> Kenneth Naito: Okay.
>> Nancy Groce: We might do more
than one, so let's start with--
>> Kenneth Naito: Of course!
>> Nancy Groce: With Kenneth.
Now, explain what you're doing
here because this is a part
of violin playing that
mostly audience doesn't see.
What are you putting on?
>> Kenneth Naito: Of course,
so I'll be playing Johann
Sebastian Bach's solo sonata
for violin in G minor, I'll
be playing the first movement,
the adagio.
So this--
>> Nancy Groce: And you're
putting on a shoulder rest?
>> Kenneth Naito: Correct,
yes, this is a shoulder rest.
This is to allow-- because
the violin is pretty thin,
so not necessarily it will
fit to a person's neck,
and so the shoulder rest
allows for the violin
to have a comfortable way
of placing the violin it.
Because without it, it could be
quite wobbly, and so it can move
around while you play.
But with the shoulder rest,
it allows the violinist
to be comfortable and
also when they play not
to have the violin move around.
>> Nancy Groce: Oh, okay.
Okay, and again,
you're playing what?
>> Kenneth Naito:
Bach's solo sonata,
the first movement, the adagio.
>> Nancy Groce: Oh, okay.
>> Kenneth Naito: So, yeah.
[ Violin Playing ]
>> Nancy Groce: That
was lovely, thank you.
>> Nate Growler: Nicely done.
>> Kenneth Naito: Okay.
>> Nancy Groce: Okay?
>> Nate Growler: Okay.
>> Nancy Groce: And now for
something completely different.
Would you like to--
oh, so you're going to
take off your shoulder rest
and Nate you're going to put
on yours, so it's individual.
>> Nate Growler: Yeah, they're
usually pretty individual.
There's all kinds of varieties.
>> Kenneth Naito: Because people
will have different neck sizes
and shoulder width as well,
so you want to find the one
that best fits for you.
>> Nancy Groce: Yeah, originally
violinists did not play with--
>> Kenneth Naito: Correct, yeah.
Well, yeah, the shoulder
rest wasn't invented
until much later, yeah.
I mean, one side
effect to having one is
that sometimes the sound
can get a little more muted.
Because when you
put it on it kind
of blocks the sound
from the violin.
But ultimately you really
want to be comfortable
when you play the violin,
so that's why people
use the shoulder rest.
>> Nate Growler: Yeah, I special
order an extra-long foot piece,
because I've got kind of a
long neck so I try to fill
that gap, a little easier.
>> Nancy Groce: Oh,
okay, interesting.
Okay, now what are
you going to play?
>> Nate Growler: Well, hearing
Kenneth do that Bach piece
so well I was thinking
about playing something also
in G minor, but it's a
fiddle tune, it's a--
Your piece was in
G minor, right?
[ Laughter ]
>> Kenneth Naito:
Of course it was!
[ Laughter ]
>> Nate Growler: It's
called Paddy Fahey's Jig.
>> Nancy Groce: Okay.
And that's Irish?
>> Nate Growler: Yeah,
it's an Irish tune.
>> Nancy Groce: Okay.
Are you going to do that and go
into another piece, or just--
>> Nate Growler: I was thinking
about just doing that one.
>> Nancy Groce: Okay.
Okay!
>> Nate Growler: Okay.
>> Nancy Groce: Let's hear that.
[ Violin Playing ]
>> Nancy Groce: Lovely.
Actually, before you sit
down, I have a request.
Since it's an American fiddle--
>> Nate Growler: Okay.
>> Nancy Groce: Could you
play an American tune also?
>> Nate Growler:
Absolutely, yeah.
Let's see.
I'll do--
>> Nancy Groce: Blackberry?
>> Nate Growler: Oh yeah, yeah.
This is called Garfield's
Blackberry Blossom.
[ Violin Playing ]
>> Nancy Groce: Lovely,
thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Nancy Groce: So we really
had three different styles
of violin playing; classical,
Irish style and American style.
Can you just tell
me what it's like,
what you like about this fiddle
or how this fiddle responds
to your different styles.
>> Kenneth Naito:
Well, actually,
since you mentioned
styles, and it's--
well, what you define
as classical,
there are many different eras of
music that define a classical.
So like the piece
I played, the Bach,
that is a baroque style piece
because it was written during
the 1600's when Bach was alive.
And so there's Baroque, there's
also classical which is defined
as like Mozart, Mozart was a
classical, there's romantic,
just much more-- as the title
suggests, gets more romantic
in that it's, there's--
>> Nancy Groce: Mid
to late 19th century.
>> Kenneth Naito: Right, and
then there's 20th century music
which is the 1900's, and
then we have modern music.
So it's not just--
classical is a very broad term
for the different types of music
that are in the classical--
So, but sorry, going back
to your question, yeah,
this violin is really good.
It was really good
for the Bach I think.
Because as Nate said, the dark
tones help the mood of the piece
which is kind of somber,
but at the same time there's
a glimpse of hope and peace.
So I think this violin
really helped to make
that the mood of the piece.
So, yeah.
>> Nate Growler: I like it
when I was just playing the tune
Garfield's Blackberry Blossom,
it's old time tune.
And there's kind of like a
rawness in old time music,
and this violin has
that sort of raw quality
to it, in a really good way.
Because it's a beautiful sound
it makes, but you're able
to kind of draw out this sort of
dark raw tone that I think fits
that style really really well.
Anyway, the Irish, it sounded
great, I mean-- it's sort of a--
I see Irish players kin of
really be able to draw a lot
of sound without using much bow,
and you can play the
strings really softly
and get a nice sound.
So you can really kind of
create that dynamic thing well.
>> Nancy Groce: So this is a
very responsive instrument?
>> Nate Growler: Absolutely.
>> Kenneth Naito: Oh yeah.
>> Nancy Groce: You get just
a real range of different--
it does what you ask it
to do as a performer?
>> Nate Growler: I
think so, definitely.
Yeah.
>> Nancy Groce: Do either of
you play an American fiddle now?
>> Kenneth Naito:
Actually I do, yes.
The violin I'm currently
playing on is
by the maker named Jeff Philips.
It's a beautiful violin.
It was actually made
I think two years ago,
so it's a very recent
violin, but he made it here--
he lives in America
and he made the violin,
it's a beautiful modern violin.
>> Nancy Groce: So, he's
continuing the tradition
that David was talking about
of fine American violin-making.
>> Kenneth Naito: Oh yeah.
There are many amazing,
wonderful modern violins.
If you ask me this question ten
years ago I would be a little
bit questionable because I feel
like the violins made ten years
ago were still a little bit iffy
in terms of the quality,
but now the art
of violin making has really
gone up in quality and--
>> Nancy Groce: But this
was made 100 years ago.
>> Kenneth Naito: Oh, well, age
also helps to a violin as well.
As a violin gets
older, it also--
>> Nancy Groce: It matures.
>> Kenneth Naito: Yeah, the
sound also becomes much--
it changes as well and I think
this violin has very well.
>> Nancy Groce: Is there
anything else you'd like to say
about this particular violin?
>> Nate Growler: Can I have it?
[ Laughter ]
I'd love to own it.
>> Nancy Groce: It's
a lovely instrument.
I want to thank you both
for coming down here.
Maybe since you played two
piece, maybe we can close
by asking Kenneth-- would you
mind playing one romantic piece,
perhaps?
>> Kenneth Naito: Of course!
Yeah, I'll play like a little
bit, excerpt from Carmen.
Carmen Fantasy by Waxman.
>> Nancy Groce: Okay.
>> Kenneth Naito: I think
that would be a great
way to end this, so.
>> Nancy Groce: Okay.
[ Violin Playing ]
>> Nancy Groce: Thank you!
Thank you both!
>> Nate Growler: Beautiful job.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.